hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
linked list cycle i know that we solved
a problem that's pretty much a harder
version of this exact problem
but in this explanation i'm going to
explain why the tortoise and hair
algorithm on a linkedlist cycle
why exactly it works and why exactly
we know for sure that it's a linear time
algorithm because i think most people
just kind of glance over why exactly
this is true so i'm going to go over
that today
and you can see that this linked list
problem is another problem from the
blind 75 list a list of 75 problems
we've been working through and tracking
on the spreadsheet the link to the
spreadsheet will be in the description
if you want to take a look
we are not quite done with this sheet
yet even though we have done all
pretty much most of the difficult medium
and hard problems on this list
so basically we're given the head of a
linked list
and we just want to determine if there
exists a cycle in this linked list or
not
and basically the definition of a cycle
is if at some point you know you get
to a node and you keep following the
pointers along that node eventually
you'll get back to the same node and if
we get back to the same node
we'll be able to do it again and again
and again basically an infinite loop
so we return true if there's a cycle we
return false if there's no cycle now the
first idea you might have is just start
at the beginning
keep going to the end keep going keep
going and eventually let's say that this
of this negative four actually pointed
to null in that case
we know okay we got to the end of a
linked list right so in that case we
return
false no cycle and that's always going
to be the case so if there's no cycle
it's really easy to detect that there's
no cycle because eventually we reach
null but if we don't reach null
right we we go along this node and we
get to we get back to the same node we
already visited but for some reason we
can't detect that so then we go to the
next node
the next node and keep doing that and
from our perspective we're just going to
say okay it's just a really
long linked list eventually we're going
to get to null right but that's not
going to be the case if there's a cycle
we never get to null we'll never break
out of this loop so we really have to
determine a way
to detect that we're visiting the same
node twice
so how can we determine if we're
visiting the same node twice well we
start at the beginning like usual and we
maintain
a hash map or a hash set in this case
where basically we take every single
node and we take the
node itself and add it to the hash set
after we have visited this node we don't
add the value because i think in this
problem there could be duplicates
right like the same value could show up
multiple times in multiple nodes
so we don't want to detect a loop that
way but we'll take the node itself
and then add it to the hash set and i
think you can do that in most languages
you definitely can in python
because the node itself is just an
object and you usually can hash an
object and so in that case we're going
to take this
visit it take this visit it take this
visit it take this visit and then
eventually we'll get
back to a node if we notice that a node
has
already been visited and now we're
visiting it twice
that obviously means that there must be
a cycle right
we can't visit the same node twice so
that means there's a cycle we detect
that and then we can return true a cycle
exists
now in this case we're only having to
visit each node about once
so the time complexity is going to be
big o of n the memory complexity is also
going to be big o of n because every
node potentially is going to be stored
in the hash set
but there's actually a way that we can
do this without using a hash set we can
do this in o of one memory and that's
the
slightly complicated algorithm i'm going
to show you that algorithm and i'm going
to show you
exactly why it works so the idea is
simple we're going to start at the
beginning of the linked list but we're
going to have two pointers this time
we're going to have a slow pointer s and
we're going to have a fast pointer
f and you may have seen this algorithm
before it's a pretty simple algorithm
once you know it but i'm gonna again
show you why exactly it works so the
slow pointer
each time is just gonna be shifted by
one
the fast pointer is going to be shifted
by
two so it's going to be here and
so originally they do start at the same
position but we're gonna look at every
position
after we've shifted it and so what's
either going to happen
obviously the fast pointer is faster
than the slow pointer so the if there is
the end of a linked list right like for
example
this points at null the fast pointer is
of course gonna
gonna reach the end of the linked list
first so if we do that
then we can return false no link no
cycle exists in the linked list but if
there
is a cycle do you see that this fast
pointer and this slow pointer are
going to meet again they're going to
meet at the exact
same position and if they meet at the
exact same position that must mean that
a cycle
exists so i'm just going to run the
simulation and then i'm going to show
you why it's always going to be the case
that these two are going to meet
if they ever reach a cycle so we just
take one more step with s right we're
only shifting it by one
f is gonna be shifted by two so first
we're gonna go to four
and then we're gonna follow the link and
reach back
to this position right the two position
so
clearly f made a loop f has gone through
the cycle
and so far we've shifted each of the
pointers twice
and so we're going to do one last shift
s is going to reach
the 4 and our f from over here is gonna
be shifted twice again
and it's gonna reach the four as well so
at this point
we're gonna just we're gonna see yes the
slow pointer and the fast pointer have
met each other how could it be possible
that they met each other if the
fast pointer was going twice as fast
because
they were in a cycle and eventually the
fast pointer no matter where they start
slow is here fast as you're eventually
the fast pointer is going to catch
up to the slow pointer let me show you
why that's always going to be the case
and why it's going to happen in linear
time
so let's say this is our cycle and i'm
not drawing it as a linked list it's
some kind of circle right and it's a
cycle
and let's say we're moving clockwise in
this cycle
first thing to notice is do you know
that every gap so let's say you know the
distance between slow and fast
that's going to be some integer value
right it's not going to be a decimal
it's going to be an integer value
and this portion is also going to be an
integer value
because the entire length of the cycle
is going to be an integer value because
you know linked list
lengths are integer values right this is
an integer one this is an integer two
uh also one so the entire list is length
two right so we're dealing with
integers here not decimals so we're
looking at the case where at with a slow
and fast pointer are at different
positions because obviously if they were
already at the same position
we're inside the cycle they're at the
same position then of course we know
we're going to return true but it could
be possible that they're at different
positions
any arbitrary position is what i'm
choosing here
and we know that the slope pointer on
one iteration is going to make
one jump right the distance it's gonna
do it's gonna move is one we know that
the fast pointer
is gonna move a distance of two
right so clearly in our simulation
eventually the fast pointer is going to
reach and surpass the slow pointer
but why is it true that they are going
to meet each other at the exact same
spot
well let's just give this distance an
arbitrary
value we know that the fast pointer will
catch up to the slow pointer and this is
the distance that it's going to have to
travel
in order to do so this is our gap that
we have to close
so let's say the the length of this gap
is 10.
if we move the slow pointer by one
we're taking the gap and increasing it
by one right
if the slow pointer gets shifted by one
we increased the gap
but then the fast pointer is not going
to quit it's gonna move by two as well
so when we move the fast pointer we're
taking the gap
and closing it by two so we're saying
plus
one minus two right do you see how
this evaluates to ten minus
one which is going to be nine so on a
single
iteration of the loop the distance
between the pointers
is being closed by one so then
how many iterations is it going to take
for the fast pointer to reach the slope
pointer well of course whatever this
length happens to be right whatever that
closing distance happens to be whatever
that
gap happens to be how big could this gap
possibly be it could only be the entire
length of the list so you know let's say
uh the fast pointer is over here where
this
distance is one so then the remaining
distance is gonna be
the entire length of the list let's call
that n
minus one so then how many iterations is
it gonna take to get this to equal to
zero
of course roughly n so that's why the
overall time complexity is
n where the length is the distance where
n is the length of the cycle which could
be the entire linked list right
so that's why it's always going to work
and
it's going to run in linear time and
maybe you didn't even care about why
exactly it works but that's okay because
once you know the fast and slow pointer
technique
the code is usually pretty easy to write
let's get into that now so like i said
we're going to start our slow and fast
pointer at the same position
and the next time that they meet each
other is how we know we've detected a
loop so obviously they're at the same
position now so we don't want to
say that there already exists a loop
because we don't know that for sure
and we're going to be shifting our fast
and slow pointers while
fast and fast dot next is not
null because we need to make sure that
fast dot next is not null
because remember we're shifting fast by
two on each
iteration and of course fast is going to
reach the end of the linked list
before slow does so if it does that then
outside of the loop we can return false
meaning that there does
not exist a cycle but on the inside
we're gonna check if there is a cycle so
we're gonna take our slow pointer
shift it by one slow dot next take our
fast pointer shift it by two
fast dot next dot next again
and now if we if they meet each other
we can say if slow ever reaches fast
then we can return true there does exist
a cycle and you could pretty much write
this loop as a do while loop in a lot of
other languages but i don't think python
supports that
so the solution is really as simple as
that linear time
constant space you can see that the
solution works and is efficient so i
hope this was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully see you pretty soon